STEVE: REPORTEDLY THE TRUMP
ADMINITRATION IS WEIGHING LEGAL
ACTIONS AND OPTIONS OVER
ALLEGATIONS THAT CHINA HORDED
CRITICAL MEDICAL SUPPLIES TO
INTENTIONALLY CORNER THE
MARKET ON THE STUFF.
A SENIOR LEGAL ADVISOR TO THE
PRESIDENT TELLING THE NEW YORK
POST, PEOPLE ARE DYING, WE HAVE
INTENTIONAL COLD-BLOODED PRE-
MEDITATED ACTION LIKE YOU
HAVE WITH CHINA THIS BE
CONSIDERED FIRST DEGREE
MURDER.
HERE TO WEIGH IN, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND FORMER SOUTH
CAROLINA CONGRESSMAN, TREY GOWDY
CONGRESSMAN, GOOD MORNING TO YOU
APPARENTLY, ACCORDING TO THIS
NEW YORK POST STORY, DURING
THE MONTH OF JANUARY, EXECUTIVES
FROM 3M AND HONEYWELL  WERE TOLD
THEY COULD NOT EXPORT ANY OF
THEIR MASKS AND PPE OUT OF CHINA
, AND AT THE SAME TIME,
CHINA WAS GATHERING THINGS FROM
ASIA, AND SOUTH AMERICA, AND THE
EU AS WELL.
NOBODY KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON IN
CHINA.
HAD THEY KNOWN, THEY PROBABLY
WOULDN’T HAVE SENT THE STUFF
BECAUSE EVERYBODY ELSE NEEDED IT
>> YOU KNOW, YOU’VE GOT A
COUPLE OF OPTIONS, STEVE.
THERE ARE INTERNATIONAL ENTITIES
WHETHER IT’S THE UNITED NATIONS,
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION,
THERE’S THE INTERNATIONAL COURT
OF JUSTICE, THERE ARE ACTUALLY
TREES THAT GOVERN THE
INTERACTIONS OF COUNTRIES AS
IT RELATES TO INFECTIOUS
DISEASE.
YOU’VE GOT THE AMERICAN BUT YOU
HAVE TO GET AROUND THE FOREIGN
SOVREIGN IMMUNITY ACT AND IF YOU
GET  AROUND THAT YOU’VE GOT
PROOF PROBLEMS.
HOW IS AN INDIVIDUAL AMERICAN
SUPPOSED TO GET INFORMATION FROM
CHINA WHEN THE REST OF THE WORLD
CANNOT?
THE TRUMP ADMINITRATION DOESN’T
NEED TO GO TO COURT TO HOLD
CHINA ACCOUNTABLE.
YOU CAN HIT THEM WHERE IT HURTS
THE MOST.
YOU CAN OSTRICIZE THEM ON THE
WORLD STAGE AND QUIT LETTING
THEIR STUDENTS COME HERE AND
STUDY.
YOU CAN MAKE THEM A PARIAH, BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY YOU CAN START
DEDUCTING THE AMOUNT OF MONEY WE
OWE THEM AND OTHER COUNTRIES OWE
THEM TO DOCK DEDUCT OUR COSTS
BUT ALL OF THE OTHER COSTS START
DEDUCTING THAT AND SEE WHAT
CHINA’S REACTION IS.
STEVE: WELL THAT’S ONE WAY TO DO
IT.
YOU KNOW, BUT CONGRESSMAN, SO
MANY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN BLAMING
CHINA OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
HEY, WHY DIDN’T YOU TELL US BACK
IN JANUARY, WHAT WAS ACTUALLY
GOING ON BECAUSE THEN THE REST
OF THE WORLD WOULD HAVE HAD A
HEADS UP.
>> THAT’S A GREAT QUESTION, AND
THE ISSUE I HAVE IS WHERE DO WE
GO TO GET THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION AND IF YOU GO TO THE
UNITED NATIONS CHINA HAS VETO.
REMEMBER THE SOUTH CHINA SEAS
WHERE WE COMPLAINED THAT CHINA
WAS BUILDING MILITARY BASES ON
LAND THEY DIDN’T OWN?
WE WON IN COURT AND CHINA SAID
WE DON’T CARE, SO IF THEY DON’T
RESPECT THE INTERNATIONAL TREAT
IES AND ENTITIES, AND THEY
ARE IMMUNE FROM OUR COURTS, WE
DON’T HAVE MUCH OF AN OPTION
EXCEPT
ADMINISTRATION-TO-ADMINISTRATION
, UNDERSTAND THE PRESIDENT SAYS
HE HAS A GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE PRESIDENT OF CHINA.
THAT’S GREAT WE SHOULD HAVE NO
TROUBLE GETTING COMPENSATION FOR
THE AMERICANS THAT HAVE LOST
THEIR LIVES AND LOST THEIR
LIVELIHOODS IF IN FACT WE HAVE A
GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM.
STEVE: AND SO SINCE THEN, SINCE
JANUARY, WHEN CHINA WAS HORDING
ALL OF THE STUFF OVER THERE, YOU
KNOW, THIS COUNTRY HAS BEEN
SCRAMBLING TO TRY TO GET MORE
STUFF AND LAST WEEK THE
PRESIDENT INVOKED THE
DEFENSE PRODUCTION ACT, AND
TOLD 3M THEY GOT TO MAKE MORE
STUFF.
WELL LAST NIGHT WE HEARD FROM
THE PRESIDENT AND HE SAID THAT
THAT HAS BEEN SOLVED, THEY ARE
WORKING WITH US AND THEY ARE
GOING TO COME UP WITH SOMETHING
LIKE 167 MILLION MASKS OVER THE
NEXT THREE MONTHS.
SEE , THAT’S THE WAY THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT IS SUPPOSED TO
WORK, AND THE PRESIDENT HAS
JUDICIOUSLY ONLY USED IT WITH
CORPORATIONS & COMPANIES, WHO
AREN’T COOPERATING WITH THE
COUNTRY.
IT’S LIKE YOU DON’T WANT TO HELP
US?
ALL RIGHT I’M GOING TO HAVE TO
PLAY HARD BALL.
RIGHT AND I THINK THE BEST
REMEDY OF ALL, STEVE, IS TO NO
LONGER HAVE TO TOK RELY ON THAT
AND THE BEST WAY TO NOT RELY IS
FOR AMERICAN MANUFACTURES TO
MAKE THE THINGS WE NEED FOR OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY, SO YOU CAN
ARGUE THAT MOTORBIKES AND SOME
OTHER THINGS ARE LUXURIES BUT
PHARMACEUTICALS, AND PROTECTIVE
GEAR ARE NOT LUXURIES.
THAT IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE, SO MAYBE THE ANSWER IS
FOR THE UNITED STATES TO BE LESS
DEPENDENT UPON OTHER COUNTRIES
FOR THINGS, THEY KEEP US FROM
DYING.
THAT OBVIATES THE NEED TO RELY
ON AN ACT AND THEN WE DON’T HAVE
TO ASK ANYONE TO DO ANYTHING
THEY’RE NOT CURRENTLY DOING
BECAUSE WE’RE ALREADY MAKING THE
STUFF IN THIS COUNTRY.
I THINK THAT’S THE LONG TERM
ANSWER THAT COMES OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC.
STEVE: DO YOU KNOW WHAT,
CONGRESSMAN GOWDY, I THINK
PEOPLE ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
JUST HEARD YOU SAY THAT AND THEY
GO THAT’S EXACTLY THE SOLUTION.
WE CAN’T EVER GET STUCK LIKE
THIS AGAIN.
SIR, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR